um
so yeah so this in this part of the
morning session I'm just going to like
highlight a few open problems
um that are sort of connected to meta
complexity and it's it's underway of
sort of illustrating what I said in the
previous part where a sort of medical
plexity as a topic and as a tool and in
terms of medical complexity is a tool
which kind of problems and problems in
other areas is that sort of relevant to
or useful for and I'll just give you
some examples I mean I don't expect you
to kind of like follow along completely
I mean just to make you aware of of some
problems and and just in case you want
to have something to start thinking
about something concrete to um
um to um to start engaging with
um so yeah so so problem one so yeah
this is a problem that we've already
kind of like seen before we asked in the
previous Talk itself which is the NP
hardness of mcsp which is probably the
major open problem about mcsp
um so again I mean mcsp is a problem
where you're given a truth table of
function or n variables or let line
variables so two tables are student
Letterland and your parameter s and you
want to know does f have circuits of
size s
so
um we don't know of mcsps and P but at
least we have some evidence about it but
we would expect that mcsp is NP hard I
mean there aren't that many natural
intermediate NP problems
um I mean there are problems like I
guess factoring which are believed to be
MP intermediate there's other problems
like Graphics modsum which at this point
probably is believed to be in polynomial
time and this is one of the few problems
left that's kind of um is not known to
be either in P nor is it known to be NP
hard and and there isn't really any
evidence that is not NP hard so mcsp is
one of the few problems where I think we
can still hope to show NP hardness
without surprising ourselves too much
um
and so that's that's the main problem
here and more generally we can ask for
which meta complexity measures as the
measure and be hard and which circuit
classes C is CM CSP and P hard and we
Define lots of meta complexity problems
in the previous talk so for each of them
each of those forms it's an NP which one
is NP hard it's K capital t k polymin KT
Etc so um
um yeah so so what can we say about MP
harness these problems so for for a long
time this kind of like Enterprise of
trying to prove Envy hardness there's
mostly like various obstacles that were
shown so um in this sort of like paper
of cabinets inside where they Define
mcsp
um they also showed that if mcsp is NP
hard under kind of some standard kinds
of reductions deterministic owner stem
reduction so deterministic reductions
mapping reductions meaning you're kind
of given X you're Computing f of x I
mean you want X to be satisfiable if
only if f of x is uh yes instead of mcsp
and these reductions are honest meaning
they don't decrease the the size too
much so the the size of the reduced
instance isn't much smaller than the
size of the initial instance it's at
most point normally smaller and all the
Productions we have in practice are
honest I mean it seems unclear how you
can gain from from decreasing the size
of your output too much
um so this this seems like very weak
conditional reduction to say that it's
the term she can honest and standard MP
heart problems are hard under such
reductions but if we can show the mcsp
is empty Hardware such reductions then
you get a kind of a breakthrough
complexity result which is that
exponential time does not have
polynomial size circuits and this is
something we don't know we seem quite
far from proving so this isn't quite
evidence against MP hardness it's just
sort of evidence for the difficulty of
showing NP hardness if you can show NP
hardness then you get a low bound out of
it and we don't yet know it seems how to
get low bounds
um and then there are several kind of
like follow-up works with similar
related results so Marianne Williams in
fact show an unconditional known NP
hardness result under a stronger notion
of reduction so um if you look at
deterministic or I think even randomized
poly log time projections so these are
very quite restricted reductions where
each output bit is just sort of an input
bit or its complement or zero one so
very restrictive kind of reduction and
where you kind of can compute which bit
it is and poly log time and input
um but it seems very restrictive but the
factors that most NP heart problems all
natural MP heart problems seem to be
hard under such reductions too
um and for mcsp we can show that it's
not NP hard under such such reductions
even parity doesn't reduce to mcsp
um so there's something different about
mcsp this kind of like an explanation of
why we found it hard just to to get MP
harness results there's something
different about it and standard kind of
Notions of hardness don't seem to to
suffice
um and then recent result with Mike's
actually showed that for example even
commonweal complexity is not empty heart
approximate
um like if you look into approximate the
hardness of approximation complexity to
a super logarithmic additive term you
want to know whether thermal complexity
is at least say NO2 or NO2 minus log N
squared then um this is not NP hard
under randomized honest not adaptive
reductions unless the problem with
hierarchical absence which should be
very surprising so
um so even if you have randomized
Productions there are some sort of like
um
yeah sort of surprising consequences
showing hardness under such reductions
so yeah there's just two I mean there's
many many other results so there's like
a whole body of work on this and
um yeah in the past 10 years lots of
results of that nature
um however none none of these results
for me really count as very strong
evidence against hardness they're kind
of like evidence for the difficulty of
showing NP hardness but not really
evidence against I mean of course these
results are evidence against hardness
with certain kinds of reductions but why
restrict ourselves reductions with this
kind we can kind of consider adaptive
reductions or non-informed reductions
there's absolutely no evidence against
randomized or adaptive reductions or
against non-uniform reductions and in
fact um like a couple of the results
that I mentioned to you in the previous
talk the results about K level T and K
capital S these problems are hard for
exponential climate polynomial space
respectively and they're hard under
normal form reductions or under adaptive
reductions so like the cases where we
know how to show hardness those are
under stronger kinds of reductions so
why not use those kinds of reductions to
try to show that mcspa is MP hard well
not that people haven't tried but they
haven't been successful so far but
especially over the past three or four
years there's been a lot of progress
towards this so um uh I mean it's a very
old result of Mass Effect is that dnf
mcsp is MP hard um so if you see mcsp
with csdnfs
um and um then over the past two or
three years there have been like many
many other results so variants of mcsp
or Medical Response which haven't really
defined but are fairly intuitive so uh
Raul elongo showed that the minimum
Oracle circuit size problem where you're
given a truth table together with an
Oracle and you want to know whether the
truth table has small circuits relative
to this Oracle that problem is NP hard
so if you have this additional Oracle as
well rather than just a true stable then
that problem is NP hard
um so illango love and Oliveira show
that multi-valued mcsp is MP hard so
here by here you don't have Boolean
circuits with circuits with a large
output
um and you want to know whether there's
a small so instead of a truth table you
have a table of values each of which is
an output of the circuit and you want to
know is there a small circuit consistent
with this table
um so it's sort of generalization of
mcsp from Boolean circuits to
multivalued circuits and that's NP hard
as well all of this under randomized
Productions
um then um elango showed that ac0
formula mcsp is NP hard so a significant
sort of like uh an extension of the
result of mass x so this is for formulas
of depth 2 and now we know for formulas
of any depths that um
formula mcsp is NP hard
um
and yeah and on the result that that all
shows that minimum formula size problems
so if you have formula mcsp you want to
know whether a truth table has a small
formula or not that's not known to be NP
hard but it's hard on the exponential
time hypothesis so if case that requires
exponential time then this problem is
hard
um so uh and Raul is going to be talking
more detail about these results and the
techniques um in world of them tomorrow
um so there's several new techniques
interesting ideas that come into this
um new and pass showed that this
conditional version of k-poly so I kind
of talked about conditional versions of
terminal complexity briefly in the last
talk where now instead of asking the
complexity of a single string you ask
for a complexible string relative to
some other string is there a short
program for for computing X from y given
some y that runs in polynomial time and
this version is NP hard as well and then
um most recently hirohara last year
showed
um I think the result that comes closest
to actually settling on the NP hardness
which is that partial mcsp is NP hard
and if you think about it this problem
is is seems very close to mcsp mcsp is a
truth table of zeros and ones here you
have zeros ones and don't knows and we
don't knows you're kind of like the
circuit can output either zero or one so
that seems very close to mcsp and you
know that that's NP hard the rich
production randomized production so on
the randomized uh yeah many wanted
options and um one difference between
this result and and the others is that
the other results
um do give some harness approximation
but very small approximation factors
um so um yeah say less than kind of like
login multiplicatively in general
um while uh yeah hirohara's results sort
of like seems to be able to this
technique seem to be able to work with
larger approximation factors so that's
on the sort of uh interesting feature of
his result
um and at this point given all this
recent progress there's pretty much
nothing else left to do but show that
mcsp is empty hot so uh not to put too
much pressure but uh yeah
um so um the problem too so just kind of
like moving away from complexity Theory
and going to learning theory so um
here's a problem about learning circuits
so we still don't fully understand which
circuit classes are learnable and which
ones are not
um so in particular if it consider the
class of circuits with and it's
unbounded fan and or and modem Gates say
mod 6 Gates some some composite modulus
um is there like an efficient algorithm
for learning such circuits from from
random examples so um let's say you
you're given kind of examples from the
uniform distribution and you want to
learn a hypothesis that predicts
um this um these examples well or the
uniform distribution that has good
agreement with um or the uniform
distribution and you allow to ask
membership queries so you allowed to ask
for your hypothesis what is value is On
Any X and then you have to Output
um sort of like a hypothesis that that
agrees with uh the the true circuit
um so is that an efficient algorithm
cause up or not an algorithm to do this
um so yeah this is one example of an
open problem and learning theory and so
this is kind of like more of a looking
for a positive result so so far we've
been talking about hardness and low
bounds so here is a potential
application of matter complexity and
getting positive results and the model
for this is this paper of Commerce
where they showed like this uh this
really kind of like uh interesting
result for a0 more P circuit so for a
long time it's been known that ac0
circuits are learnable in Quasar
polynomial time but it wasn't known how
to extend this to a0 more P circuits and
um crk showed this for any Prime P
um and still open though for larger
circuit classes and even for some
circuit class that are incomparable with
a01p
um so you might ask well what does this
have to do with meta complexity I
already briefly said to you I mean
mentioned the reason why medical
complexity might be relevant but here uh
let me kind of expand on it a bit so CIA
derived their learning algorithm by
establishing connection between from
natural proofs which are very much meta
complexity notion useful against the
circuit class and learning algorithms
for the circuit class so if you have
like a proof low bound technique against
a circuit class and that yields a
natural proof against the circuit class
you can then transform that to a
learning algorithm for the circuit class
so it's like a close relationship
between complexly low bound techniques
yielding National proofs and learning
algorithms
and as I said in the previous talk
National proves useful against C is
essentially a zero average case
algorithm for CM CSP for the uniform
distribution so it's very closely tied
to to meta complexity
um so by their kind of like result for
any large enough circuit Class C
um natural proofs useful against
sub-excial size C circuits implied quasi
polynomial time learning algorithms for
C and now if we kind of like consider C
equals ACC 0 we don't know how to Show
Low bounds here but the problem is we
don't know how to get lash of proofs
against
um circular size
um so
um and kind of like Williams results is
the angry method um we didn't we know
how to get like low balance on X to the
NP against some expensive size h0
circuits but we don't yet know how to
get natural proofs so we don't know how
to analyze these low bound techniques in
a way that we can get natural proofs
from them and if we did then we'll be
able to get
um our learning algorithm for these
classes
um so that's about getting learning from
low balance and we could also think of
like reversing the connection about
getting new low bonds from learning
um so um this kind of connection that I
told you about allows us to derive
learning elements from low bound
techniques that yield natural proofs
um and in fact you can even reverse the
connection so there's a line of work and
a paper of mine that you got all aware
that's one of the more recent ones where
you can get low bounds in bpx from
non-trivial learning algorithms so any
learning algorithm that runs on less
than Brute Force search can be used to
get a low Bound in bpx against a circuit
class
um so for example if you could derive
non-trivial learning algorithms for
these circuit classes ACC 0 adaps two
tc0 these are sort of Frontier classes
in terms of proving low bounds these are
the classes where we don't have any sort
of explicit load bounds then we will get
some new information for example a bpx
was normalcy
and in fact this connection from line to
low bounce was even for Quantum
algorithms so
um in kind of a recent work
um it was shown that even Quantum
algorithms that are non-trivial Learners
give you low bounds and in Quantum
version of exponential time against C so
it's it seems like a fairly kind of
robust connection
um yeah so with each of these questions
that I mentioned there are other
questions related to them that are kind
of um yeah kind of interesting to attack
as well so here the main question is
about getting a new learning algorithm
but you could kind of reverse that and
try to get like a new low bound as well
um so problem three is sort of like
trying to use meta complexity is a
hardness assumption so um like we've
used many different harness hypothesis
and complexity Theory and of course the
most popular is npn or equal to p and NP
hardness there's also the unique games
conjecture to try to understand an
approximity of various approximation
problems there's fibers hypothesis which
is kind of a an average case hardness
assumption
um there's the existence of one-way
functions cryptographic hardness
assumptions and then there's sort of
fine-grained harness assumptions such as
exponential time hypothesis and the
strong exponential time hypothesis the
special time hypothesis says that that
KSAT requires like time 2 to the Omega n
and the strong expression time
hypothesis kind of says that it requires
time like uh close to 2 to the N
um as SK increases so um these
assumptions are used in various contexts
and complexity to classify the hardness
of problems where we don't quite know NP
hardness
um or to get strong approximation
factors so for example harness
approximation learning fine grained
analysis and so on so there's a host of
harness assumptions that used and
something that hasn't been done very
much is to use hardness hypothesis based
on meta complexity assumptions right so
um these are so for example in
prosperity or circuit size uh in
polynomial time up to a large factor or
maybe even in some exponential time or
to a large Factor perhaps this can be
used to get um to unify some of the
results that have been shown already
with the hardness hypothesis listed here
um let me kind of um zoom in in one of
those figures hypothesis so FICA
hypothesize that KSAT is hard to solve
in an average case sense so you let's
say you're given a CNF that generated
randomly each of the K losses is
generated completely uniformly at random
there's a linear number of them and each
of them is generated completely
uniformly random instead of all K
Clauses
um and the question now is well you want
to certify that this formula is
satisfiable unsatisfiable and you want
to correctly satisfy certify a
non-negligible fraction of these of
these instances and you don't want any
instances to be wrongly certified so
that's what it means to solve this
problem on average
and if you assume that this is hard to
do I mean yeah we don't really have
worst case to average case hardness for
case app so we don't know that this
follows from MP hardness but let's
assume that this problem is hard then
you can get some stronger in a
Prosperity results for various problems
such as like densis case subgraph
maximum bipart athlete and so on
um and we have no good hardness results
um in terms of NP hardness for these
problems
so um so there's this paper there's a
follow-up paper for electronics so
there's some work on these kind of like
average case audience assumptions which
give you stronger in a prosperity and
the results and then there's also
results for hardness of learning based
on similar hypothesis so danelli and
shalev Schwartz and
um there's been some follow-up work
recently they showed learning of fact
hardness of fact learning dnfs based on
similar hypothesis except that now it's
not a linear number of Clauses but some
super linear number of them that you
have hardness for so Ficus hypothesis
related both the hearts of approximity
and to learning but it's an average case
hypothesis so one question is but maybe
you could replace fiber's hypothesis by
a meta complexity hypothesis
implies hardness of MK Capital TP on
average so if you use this as hard as
hypothesis that would give you a
stronger result but perhaps you could
even use like inner cross multiple mktp
worst case harness assumption rather
than average case harness assumption and
intuitively these reductions of fiber
and then early and Schwartz the previous
slide they do exploit compressively I
mean the way they use their average case
harness assumption is
um using compressibility so perhaps some
kind of medical complexity assumption
would be useful as kind of replacement
might be the right thing to use in order
to get results of this phone
um so I think this is a Direction that's
not been explored very much and might be
a productive one to to look at
okay so
um
yeah so the next two kind of like
directions relate to kind of average
case complexity and um before kind of
like talking about them more I'd just
like to to remind you okay in case
you've seen it before or to tell you
about
um the five worlds of average case
complexity defined by pagliazzo in a
survey in 95 a personal view of average
case complexity so it's a very
influential survey so um essentially
um like the survey talks about these
these these different kind of like
worlds um based on our kind of like
ignorance about the truth the truth of
complexity statements
um so algorithmic is a world where NP
equals P so where NP is easy
um so I mean of course there's lots of
advantages to that world but we can't do
kind of like crypto in that world
because the obfuscation with no other
crypto so algorithmaker as a world where
MP equals P
um and then there's heuristica where MP
is worst case hard
um but NP is easy on average right so
um this line here so as you go along
this line This complex assumptions gets
stronger and stronger the worst case
harness when people one-way functions
existing to publicly crypto existing and
really it's a the question of whether
you're in between two of these
assumptions so here you're you you have
worst case honors when people because
you're the right of this point but
you're you have average case easyness of
NP so heuristic as a world where np's
average case easy and MP is worst case
hard and we don't know how to rule that
off we don't know any worst case to
average case reductions for NP so we
don't know how to rule out the existence
of feudal sticker
um and then there's this question of
like okay suppose you did have average
case hardness can you get any crypto
from it right so there's this world
passy learn which is some of the worst
of all possible worlds because if you in
touristica you have average case easily
so you can solve problems on average and
that seems like a good thing generally
here you can't solve problems on average
in NP on average because MP's average
case hard
um but you also don't have crypto so you
neither have crypto nor do you have
um average case solubility uh of NP so
that's kind of like a very pessimistic
World pestilent then there's minicrypt
where you know that one-way functions
exist but you don't have stronger kind
of crypto system you don't have public
key crypto and finally cryptomania where
public key crypto exists and of course
you could kind of come with many other
words depending on which complexity kind
of statements assumptions you're
interested in
so I mean the current state of
complexity theory is is sort of like two
um yeah we certainly can't hope to to
solve P was MP so we don't know whether
we live in in algorithmic or not
um so uh yeah so there's no hope of kind
of like figuring out precisely which
world we live in but we could hope to
kind of eliminate or get rid of some of
these intermediate worlds and doing that
would correspond to coming up with new
reductions right like like showing that
this follows from this or one of your
functions existing follows from NP being
hard on average for the publicly crypto
existing problems from one-way functions
existing so that would be a way to kind
of like annihilate these worlds in
between to get rid of minicrypt or
personality heuristic
um and and these are I mean of course
the important questions in average case
complexity and crypto and it turns out
that meta complexity is kind of like a
useful kind of like tool to to kind of
address
um some of these questions
so
um so yeah so here's problem four so a
problem four is kind of like ruling out
uh heuristica
um so yeah so we have here uh hiriska
which is that NP is hard in the worst
case and is easy in the average case and
we won't rule that out so we want to
show that worst case out of the MP
implies average case hardness of MP
foreign
so this kind of like question of worst
case to average case reductions is one
that's been studied a lot in complexity
Theory and we we know quite a lot about
this question we know that for example
like problems and polynomial space and
exponential time have worst case average
case reductions they have random
self-productions which give you worst
cases obvious case reductions
um we also know it for some problems
that are kind of like quite weak
complexity-wise so for example if you
look at like problems and logarithmic
space or nc1 and you look at them with
respect to weaker circuit classes then
those problems are worst case to average
case reductions too
um but in between we don't really know
so for polynomial time for NP for
polynomial hierarchy we don't really
have a sense of whether there are worst
case to average case reductions
um and um yeah when you kind of like
Define this question you could Define it
in many possible ways because your worst
case hardness could be with respect to
any of these classes to deterministic
polynomial time to zero error
probabilistic time boundary error
probabilistic time or even just known
you from polynomial size and the average
case hardness could either be a zero
error version where the algorithm is
required to be correct and never make a
mistake or bounded error where it makes
it makes mistakes with some small
probability of the distribution so yeah
there's many possible versions you can
Define and it would be interesting to
get an implication for any of these
versions We don't really have like an
application for worst case honest case
hardness for any of these versions of
the problem
and um
and there's kind of reasons for this so
there's like various kind of obstacles
to doing this so um I mean these
obstacles kind of indicate that the
techniques we know for like larger
classes such as polynomial space like
special time can't be used for NP
um so Bob now and travisan building on
495 and bomb showed that there's this
notion of a black box non-adaptive worst
case to average case reduction which
like the known reductions for Poland
space and exponential plan do satisfy
and um such reductions don't exist for
NPR unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses so um what is a black box case
reduction well like if you want a worst
case to average case production you're
starting off from some NP problem MP
heart problem says that and you want to
construct some problem l and a
distribution mu such that that problem L
is an NP and it's hard over me on
average right and um the Black Box means
that given any algorithm from for Mu uh
for L over mu the the organ that you
then get for sat uses this algorithm in
Black Box way so given any sort of
algorithm a a for that solves L on
average you're able to use that in a
black box way to solve sat in the worst
case that's what Black Box means and not
not adaptive just means that um yeah
that you don't make adaptive queries
so um so this is kind of like a natural
notion and it turns out that this notion
is impossible to achieve for NP unless
the form of hierarchical absences so
that's one kind of obstacle there's also
other kinds so there's a relativization
obstacle so
um in pagliazzo and Watson show that
worst case to obstacles reductions for
NP control devices oracles relative to
which they fail is oracle's related to
which NP is very hard on average
um but very easy
um so very hard in the worst case but
very easy on average
there's also other kinds of evidence
Viola gave evidence against hardness
amplification within the parliament
hierarchy so if you want to go from like
a problem L to problem L Prime and L
Prime is sort of like um is Napoleon
hierarchy with Oracle access to L so if
you want to go from worst case RNs to L
to average k sound as well Prime and L
Prime is the polynomial hierarchy uh
with Oracle axis to L then that actually
implies average unconditionally so
that's that's Viola's result so there's
kind of like various kind of like piece
of evidence that this might be hard to
achieve
foreign
in various ways so um so there was sort
of like
um building on this kind of like uh of
this inflation work of Commerce you know
powers of cameras and kolaver there was
a worst case to errorless average case
reductions for matter complexity
problems so yeah we don't have any sort
of like leads on getting worst case to
bounded error average case reductions we
don't know anything about that question
at all but for errorless uh average case
hardness we do have some reductions for
these meta complexity problems
um and these are Medical Response which
are not believed to be in co-amp so um
if you could show that these kind of
problems were NP hard then we'd be done
because
um their NP hardness would imply average
case hardness right
um there's just one detail which is that
um like we don't quite get a worst case
to average case reduction but we get a
reduction from
um approximating these problems to
average case easily so
um if these problems are hard to
approximate we get average case harness
from that and so we need to show a
stronger antihana result for proximately
in order to rule out your sticker using
these results
so that's One Direction but it already
gives you some new information that
these problems which
um yeah which look hard and which do
have a sketched average case Productions
um then um they're sort of like um this
result of hirohara where they showed
that
um if there's like a worst case
assumption which is kind of like a very
strong worst case assumption so view P
so the class of problems that are unique
polynomial time or there's a unique
witness for the S instances if that's
not in time to the order n over log n
that that implies the NP Norton p on
average so um it's kind of like a strong
worst case honest assumption but then
you get an average case hardness as a
conclusion from it
um and kind of what's interesting here
is that the statement of this result
doesn't really refer to metal complexity
at all but the proof techniques do rely
heavily on metal complexity so it seems
that
um meta complexity is somehow kind of an
important notion here to understand the
status of this question
um and there's sort of like a randomized
kind of like version of the result too
more recently
um like if you have like a randomized
worst case assumption for up you get
like
um a randomized average case a
conclusion for NP
so um yeah so so so there's some
progress and in order to completely draw
our touristica we need to prove some
kind of like empty Hardware reserves
which we don't know how to show we don't
even know how to show and be hardness of
mcsp without any approximation uh Factor
so that's the first step but
um perhaps eventually there might be a
way of showing strong enough NP hardness
results that you can combine it with
these reductions to get the the that
heuristic doesn't exist
any questions
okay so so so that's um yeah so that's
about heuristica and then yeah there's
also this question about pestilence so
um
like does the average case hardness of
NP imply that one-way functions exist
right so
um yeah it's kind of Fairly standard
that one-way functions imply the average
case hardness of NP so if one-way
functions exist then NP is average case
hard
um and the question is whether you can
kind of like um yeah get a Converse you
can you get a one-way function existing
from arbitrary average case owners of NP
we don't know if a very specific
problems that average case honesty's
problems implies existence of one-way
functions
um like factoring for example or
discrete log but yeah but these are for
specific problems and we're interested
in just the general assumption about
average when we and whether that's
sufficient for one-way functions
existing
um and there's some kind of like
evidence also that this might be hard to
do there's like relativized worlds in
which this doesn't exist
um meaning that there's really too much
worlds where NP is average case hard but
one of your functions don't exist
um so any proof technique that's used
here can't relative wise
um so that's sort of like a bottleneck
and attacking this question
um and again there's sort of like some
progress where I'm at a complexity
um so the kind of the most significant
work here is by Leon pass who kind of
like characterize one-way functions by
an average case hardness assumption on
polynomial time bounded common growth
complexity so so they show that one-way
functions exist if and only if
polynomial time or more complexity is
hard in a certain sense on average or
the unform distribution in a certain
bounded error sense or the informal
distribution so this is kind of like um
uh yeah kind of a breakthrough because
it's sort of um allowed us to
characterize one of the functions
completely using meta complexity and
then there's been other
characterizations since
um one of your functions exist if even
common raw complexity which is
non-computable problem it's hard on
average or any sample distribution to
approximate or if the minimum circuit
size if circuit size is hard and
averaged to approximate over look
so-called locally sample distributions
and many possible there's many
characterizations in this kind
and these characterizations kind of like
open the way towards possibly ruling out
both basilan because if you could show
that as kind of a reasonable
distributional version of this problem
is NP hard then
um or hard for average MP then you'd be
down and leaving pass have kind of like
a result towards that where they have
this problem the conditional version of
K poly they show their problem is MP
hard and they show that if this problem
is hard on average or the uniform
distribution that implies that one-way
functions exist
so on first side looking at this result
you might think we are done I mean she
has an empty heart problem and it's
hardness on average implies that one-way
functions exist but the problem is that
by hardness on average of NP you mean
over some sample distribution not over
this specific distribution that they
pick here so in order to rule out
pestilent you need this to hold for
um you need this implication to hold
even when you have any sample
distribution here not just hardness of
the uniform distribution
um so that's the gap between what's
known so far and what we need in order
to um to rule out pessimand but again it
seems we made some progress there using
ideas for matter complexity
um note again that this question on the
surface doesn't seem to have anything to
do with very complexity but the
techniques used are uh yeah closely
related to to my complexities
foreign
so yeah a couple more problems about um
that are more crypto related yeah
you said this doesn't look like related
to Medical complexity made a statement
but I'm mcsp and Kate Paul is by
definition that are complex sorry I mean
the question of ruling out passenger
doesn't seem obviously related yeah so
uh yeah
um yeah because yeah the sort of like
the broad theme of the stock is how
medical packs team plays a role in areas
where it might not obviously
yeah and then
um so there's this kind of like
so this isn't that precise a question
perhaps but I think it's an interesting
direction to look at so
um
are there like
in other natural other variety of
natural distributional problems so
Savage case hardness characterizes uh
it's across the existence of the one-way
functions that president is the one-way
functioning so where there's an
equivalence transition to one of the
one-way functions
and the motivation for this question is
sort of like an analogy completeness
right so
um part of the reason why sat is such an
important problem is because it plays
because the MP complete and because it's
it can be used in so many interesting
reductions right so
um cooking level show that sounds empty
hard but if they really showed that and
then there wasn't progress after that
well uh starting with such an important
problem what really kind of like pushed
the field further was results of cop and
others showing that all these other
natural problems combatorial problems
and problems from other domains are
empty hard
um so sat kind of like gives you a pound
of reviews from to um and show them many
many other natural problems that MP hard
um so I've got some worst case
complexity we have like a very clean
picture of what's MP compared and what's
not because we don't know if the app for
the mcsp related problem so most
problems we know whether they're NP or
or they'll be harder than much it
eventually hard
um but this is far from being the case
with average case complexity so you have
like a variety of problems and
distributions and um it's kind of it's
quite wild in the sense that it's not
really clear like whether natural
problems or natural distributions on
them are hard or not
um so that's kind of like
um quite unclear
um so I think this result of Leon pass
showing that Colorado complexity
uniform distribution that's in a sense
one-way functions right it's kind of
hard if and only if one-way functions
exist so let me just prefer that as
one-way function completeness for now so
that was given by that result was given
by Leon pass and then there's further
problems given in follow-up work but all
of these problems are medical complexity
problems right so um they're all sort of
connected to commonweal complexity and
variant software and kind of like
approximating it over natural
distributions
um so uh
it's yeah that's nice but is there a
natural distribution problem that's not
a very complexity flavor and is
equivalent to means right so so that's
not so clear
um
and and that's what we'll be looking for
I mean there's lots of natural
interesting other space
um complexity problems distribution
problems and can we show for some
problems Define combinatorialing
um or in some other way that that's
equal to one-way functions existing
so that would be like the analog of cops
theorem in the sign of average case
complex too
um so yeah so that's the question here
is there a natural description problem
with normal Medical Practice equal
interviews
um and part of the motivation is simply
that we don't really have any techniques
to get average case induction so we
don't have many techniques to reduce
distribution problems to each other
um so 11 has this kind of theory of
average case complexity where there are
Notions of completeness and there are
complete problems but they aren't
um yeah there are many natural complete
problems and many cases we don't know if
reductions exist so for example we
already know of the reduction between
three star and four sides uniform
distribution
um in these questions same kind of an
answer seems unclear
um so given this sort of like
um lack of information I mean maybe one
path towards achieving such reductions
average case reductions is by
characterizing these hard distributional
problems using crypto Primitives for
using other Primitives so if you can
show the one say this hard
distributional problem a has is equal to
existing one-way functions and some
other problem B is also equivalent to
the existence of one of your functions
then you know that a can be reduced to
each other though that might not be easy
to see otherwise and in fact yeah this
path was taken to show the equivalence
of various distributional medical
complexity problems which superficially
look quite different now we know that
they're all equivalent with regard to
their complexity because they're all
equivalent to the existence of one-way
functions but can this sort of like
technique be applied to other natural
problems like combinatorial ones like
maybe versions of planted Clique or
versions of
um like figures hypothesis problems like
that it'd be interesting to get any
example of that kind
yeah so I'm covering quite a kind of
like a wide I mean a lot of territory
here but I mean the point is not to kind
of like completely understand everything
but to kind of pose questions that so
one or two of these might interest you
and and allow you get a handle on on and
on kind of like um connections with meta
complexity so that's really the goal so
um if something's unclear that's
perfectly fine and many of these things
I should uh remark will be kind of like
addressed and followed up in further
talks so for example what I said about
learning will kind of like
um be addressed by volunteering later
today and
um what I said about um heuristica
um shuishi stock will will address that
I mean the first problem on NP hardness
probably longer stock will address it
and these problems that I just mentioned
related things we address vital and
Rafael so um there will be more on these
uh topics uh later on the boot camp
um so yeah this problem seven is
questionable basic other cryptographic
parameters and meta complexity so far
most of the work on crypto versus meta
complexity has been about one-way
functions about gun characterizing
one-way functions and the problem is Are
there natural assumptions that yield
other cryptographic Primitives like
trapdo functions the position resistant
hash functions or maybe even industry
obfuscation so are there kind of meta
complexity Notions that are connected to
these um these crypto Primitives so
we've been successful in characterizing
owfs in multiple ways but there's been
limited progress on other parameters so
far
um and yeah I mean I I'm not an expert
at all on obfuscation but just to say a
little bit about it so
um and Industry obfuscater is just an
algorithm which
um applied to any two programs are
functionally equivalent it produces
programs that are completely
indistinguishable so um uh so it's kind
of like it obfuscates these programs
that you can't really tell anything
about them apart from their input output
behavior
um and intuitively this is about the
difference between white box and black
box computation it's a like a program I
mean it's sort of like a white box
object but then you kind of process it
in a way so it becomes a black box
object you can't tell anything about
what the the program actually was like
only about working compute so it seems
as though medical complexity ideas
should be somewhat related to this
um but we just don't have many results
along these lines yet so
um yeah
um and only recently have we kind of
achieved industrial obfuscation with
standard assumptions so there's been
kind of a lot of work on that even more
recently and it would be interesting if
there were kind of like meta complexity
assumptions that came to them picture to
simplify these characterizations or
played a role here one result we do know
is that initial obfuscation is related
to
um the connection between mcsp and sat
if IO exists then if mcsp is easy then
MP equals p and that's in like um an old
paper of common godsky and all and in a
paper of uh empowers the cabinets in
local which
so we do I mean there's some work on it
but not very much and I think there's an
opportunity to explore these connections
further
so the last three problems are going to
be about like proof complexity logic
algebraic complexity so um yeah kind of
like um shifting areas again
um so
um yeah so here are the emphasis on kind
of like the question of proving proof
complexity low balance so we've seen
already in the previous talk and um yeah
um that that circuit complexity low
balance are closely tied to
understanding meta complexity further
through natural proofs and and and
through other connections uh but what
about proof complexity so
um
the problem here is to give complexity
evidence against
um the efficient probability of low
bounds for proof systems such as frago
extended fragrance so we've tried very
hard
um just as in circular complexity to
prove proof commercial load bounds and
we've kind of like failed even more
badly in a sense I mean it's turned out
to be even harder to show support on a
low balance for propositional proof
systems than for corresponding circuit
classes so for example we have low
balance against a0 mode P circuits but
we don't know any low bounds for
propositional formulas in the proof
system is remote P fragor where the
version of the frag approved system
where the lines are a zero morph piece
circuits so this is still unknown so we
seem to be kind of like behind the state
of the art in circuit complexity
um at least in circuit complexity there
are barriers of various kinds there's a
virtualization barrier natural proofs
barrier the algebraization barrier in
the proof compressive World there isn't
even satisfactory kind of barriers of
the not very many there aren't any good
explanations of this
um there have been some conjectures that
sort of low bounds are hard to show
efficiently in fragile external friend
but these are just conjectures and
pointers to tie these conjectures to
other complexity or take questions
somehow
so
um and you might ask well how is meta
complexity sort of involved here well so
far as we've discussed meta complexities
about the computational complexity of
problems that are themselves who are
competition complexity but similar ideas
and techniques will be useful to study
the proof complexity of formulas that
are about proof complexity so formulas
are expressed proof complexity low bonds
or kind of related proof complexity
um yeah this is in a sense very very
similar task
um and that's what sort of uh involved
here and there's some kind of recent
progress
um where for some like very strong proof
systems some systems that are even kind
of non-explicit you can show that that
low bounds for these proof systems are
hard to show propositionally in any
proof system
um and you can also show some sort of
limitations of showing that MP is not
co-mp slash Poly on average and sort of
bounded arithmetic so there's there's
some work on kind of like the hardness
of Brewing like proof compression low
bounds
um low versions of MP versus go NP
um but none of these results so far
address fresh or extended Fragger
therefore other proof systems when
there's a result for the ideal proof
system which is maybe the most concrete
of these proof systems so far but it
will be nice to get some kind of
information about how hard it was to
show Fredo external trigger low bonds so
from the point of view of meta
mathematics and proof complexity this
would be a natural Direction
um to uh to to approach
um
big problem now so yeah so this is
another kind of common proof complexity
which is sort of at the other end of the
spectrum so fragment extended frag are a
strong proof systems where
um we can prove many of the things we do
in complexity Theory and then there's
resolution which is a much weaker proof
system whereas proof system with a lot
of practical
um sort of impact because like for
example Clause learning which is one of
the most popular ways of doing sat
solving can be formalized within that so
it's very kind of like important to
understand
um how to how hard it is to produce or
compute resolution proofs when short
ones exist and that's what this notion
of automatability is about it's about
proof search so if you if you know that
a short proof exists for propositional
formula in a proposal proof system how
hard is it to find right
um question yeah I mean this sort of
like might remind you of like what I
said about learning in the previous talk
where learning was really about solving
the search version of mcsp I mean like
if there's a small circuit can you find
it efficiently and this is kind of like
an analog of that improves complexity
they're just a short proof can you find
it efficiently
um the standard notion of automatically
asks you to find a short proof
um in time polynomial the size of the
proof
um and that's the standard notion of the
study but there's kind of like a weaker
notion where if there's a system I mean
like um there's some system r that you
want to find proofs in but you don't
necessarily want to find an R proof you
want to find a proof on some other proof
system like um some other cool system Q
which might be stronger and as long as
it's the proof in some system and you
can check it maybe you'll be happy
um so
um you don't necessarily want to find a
proof in R it's just as long as a small
R proof exists you want to find a proof
in some system Q so that's a weaker
notion and so it requires stronger
assumptions to rule out
um and it would be extremely interesting
if resolutions were weakly automatable
so that would be uh kind of like an
amazing result but we don't really know
the status of that yet and the question
is to give compress theoretic evidence
for or against the weak on automated
resolution
um and I mean recently like just a
couple of years ago it's been shown that
automatically resolution doesn't be hard
and that's an amazing result it is an
open problem for a very long time and um
it was kind of sold in spectacular
fashion by outside Mueller so um for the
there's been a sequence of works over
the years giving evidence against weak
Automotive today but this most
cryptographic evidence
um for systems that are strong like
actually even constant depth tracker
um and then there's even like
connections with Game Theory
um but there's recent work about serious
and Muller shows that if you're looking
at kind of the standard notion
automabilities in fact NP hard
um and in fact what's shown is that it's
kind of like NPR to approximate the
proof size and resolution to even the
very large factors essentially the best
possible result
um so this is about automability and the
question now is what can you say about
weak automative for resolution we really
don't know much about recovery for
resolution
um and what about the role of meta
complexity here well I mean proof search
is sort of like internally tired of meta
complexity it's about the computational
complexity of finding short proofs but
Additionally the proof technique of
atseras and Muller uses sort of medical
complexity ideas and that's the case
with follow-up work on this as well
so we'll hopefully hear about this more
Susanna's talk on Friday
um maybe a bit in Tony's talk as well
um so
um I think this is like a particular
Target problem but there are kind of
like other problems here about
automatically it's just so and sold
um and then
um finally a problem about kind of
algebraic natural proofs so um like
we've looked at like the standard notion
of Russia proofs due to Ross Brown
rudish I haven't said very much about
them just about how they're connected to
meta complexity
um and um I just want to say that like
meta complexity is relevant also to um
questions in the algebraic world like
you know asked about the algebraic world
at the end of the previous talk so
um for algebraic low bonds I mean are
there like matter complexity ideas that
are kind of relevant there
um and a concrete problem here is to
give complexity theoretic evidence that
no algebraic natural proofs against
polynomial size algebraic circuits right
so in the Boolean setting Roswell showed
that one-way functions exist then there
are no National proofs useful against
performance size Boolean circuits I mean
Super normal size Boolean circuits and
that's been a very influential result in
Boolean circuit complexity it's sort of
like um stop people from crying for
circular bonds for a while and uh so
it's it's it and it kind of really kind
of like tells us about yeah the The Meta
mathematical aspects of circuit
complexity and we don't really know very
much about this in the algebraic setting
is there an analog of this result in the
algebraic setting
so let me say a little bit more about
what I mean sorry
[Music]
um yeah let's just say that you're
working with some field characteristics
zero rationals
um so um natural proves like Boolean
versus algebraic just to say a bit more
about what I mean so what is the
national proof in a Boolean setting it's
just sort of like an efficiently
computer property of Truth tables so you
have like some property of Truth tables
of Boolean function and this property is
only Satisfied by hard truth tables
those that don't have small circuits and
moreover a kind of a non-nexual fraction
of such truth they will satisfy the
property so a one over polynomial and
capital N where energy size a truth
table fraction of um truth table satisfy
um this property that's what a natural
proof is and it turns out that for like
the standard control and algebraic
techniques for growing low bounds in its
weak circuit classes you can extract
from them a natural proof against a
certain class
but um you can't hope to do that with
General Boolean socket low bounds if you
believe in cryptography
um so there's been kind of an algebraic
version of it that sort of like studied
uh in these two papers
um where I mean just as a natural proof
of sort of a property of two stable they
come to these meta polynomials which are
polynomials
um whose variables represent the
coefficient vectors of other polynomials
and you want these polynomials to be
non-zero only on the gaussian vectors of
hard polynomials so um you wanted to
vanish on all the easy polynomials and
to and to be non-zero on the hard ones
just as natural proofs
um our properties that are satisfied by
hard truth tables and I'm not satisfied
by easy ones here um the polynomials are
zero on social vectors of the easy
polynomials so it's like a natural
analog in the algebraic world
and um it turns out that known algebra
glow bound techniques also yield natural
proofs in algebraic settings so so that
part of it is interesting but it's
unclear how to formalize and argue about
like crypto in the settings about
getting like negative results so so is
it the case that Azure low bounce in
general are hard to prove or not it's
unclear yeah is there an analog of like
uh
personal medical practice
[Music]
um so uh yeah so it's kind of unclear
how to formalize an audio crypto is
there a notion of crypto in the
algebraic setting I mean these are
questions that have been kind of looked
at by various people but there's no kind
of satisfactory answer to it so
essentially we have no evidence that
Azure International proofs don't exist
it could be that algebraic natural tools
just exist that's possibility too but um
that seems too good to be true so um
there's been some kind of like recent
kind of work kind of like addressing um
these questions so um and this it's kind
of conflicting evidence so there's like
this paper
um which gives kind of like algebraic
natural proofs that are useful against
circuits with bounded coefficients but
it's unclear how much it says about
General algebraic circuits I mean that's
yeah so it's unclear whether it gives
any evidence that advocacy in general
exists and then there's this other paper
by a subset of the authors which shows
that under standard hardness assumption
the permit is hard then there are no
algebraic natural rules useful against
vnp so vnp is just the class of
polynomials are reducible to the
permanent I mean of course we want to
prove low balance against VP I mean I
guess polynomial size algebraic circuits
not against the permanent so
um this isn't really telling us all that
much but but this is sort of like
conflicting piece of evidence it's
unclear whether truth law is they don't
get clear evidence either for or against
the existence natural proofs and what I
think this this tells us is that yeah
maybe algebraic matter complexity needs
for the study
um to understand like The Meta
mathematics of algebraic circuit load
bounds on better
so yeah so that's just kind of a cross
selection of problems I mean which kind
of ranges quite widely across areas I
mean there's many others that yeah
didn't get time to cover I mean problems
about like is there a proof of the PCP
theorem using meta complexity or
problems about Quantum control
complexity and so forth so there's many
others but just to give you a sense of
like how broad the field is potentially
and also hopefully to kind of interest
you in one or more of these problems um
so that you can get a handle on on on on
what this uh the semester is about
and as I said before I mean most of
these directions these problems will be
followed up um and other talks in the
boot camp and yeah you'll hear about
them okay
[Applause]
time for questions
I mean yeah I don't think it's been good
yeah
understood
[Music]
you said it's not monetary
complexity so is there something that is
analog to weak yes
I mean so
the question is um so with weak
automatically is like monotone meaning
um that is like a strong Pro system is a
weaker Pro system is also weekly
admittable but um
yeah like with mcsp we saw that
different circuit classes say cmcsp
might have completely different
complexity to C Prime and CSP if C Prime
is larger than C is okay whether it's
harder or easier in general so I guess
Edo is asking about whether there's an
analog in a circuit complexity world of
like weak automatically and that analog
was improper learning so if you have
like a circuit class and you want to
learn circuits from that class but you
love to learn them by General Boolean
circuits rather than just by Circuit for
that class that's sort of the analog of
weak automated Boolean circuit setting
the Boolean setting and indeed like uh
results for hardness of learning I mean
hardness and proper learning all of
these results go through crypto
assumptions or assumptions like versions
of sagos hypothesis and we don't really
have like empty hardness
um in that setting so
um yeah so it's kind of like it related
in a way to the question of whether weak
automatic Equity
um for we coordinatory we don't demand
like NP hardness any sort of reasonable
hardness assumption
um that rules out MP hardness that's
sorry the rules are recovered you will
be interesting
they're just comments like it's not a
Perfect Analogy though because like
ruling circuits can simulate every other
circuit model would be picked up well
there is no super first is the driving
problem yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's true yeah so like bullion circles
but the professional world doesn't know
this slides that there is a new result
that is
yeah so the old result was about back
learning DNA so Omega login terms and
the new result is about tackling DNS is
Omega one terms so it's just like a
stronger parameter
um
but they use a different assumption they
use like local prgs and security local
3rd so phone numbers
but I should say that um I mean there is
get like a given um you can get like two
to the square root S lifetime so that's
that's like this interesting paper where
like the sort of informal connections
between learning automatically studied
in more details by Tony and others
you're going to mention that talk and so
you can use like learning algorithms
like what's known about learning Alpha
dnf so you know some non-trivial
learning for dnfs you can use these
ideas to get weak on waitresses
let's thank the speaker again